[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode six too many
tuna sandwiches now if you're back this
week i'm happier back because i was
pretty hard on last week's episode and i
still stand by it but what really
excites me is this episode was a prime
example of what to correctly do when
writing and i didn't have all these
contrived things and it felt more like
the season we had before last episode
and felt like actually a good tv show a
good pace a natural rhythm to it and
everything was moving the plot forward
but not in a rushed way and i felt
invested in every character here so what
they move along well is that
dexter knows now that kirk caldwell is
really interested in his son he knows
that harrison is going to work for him
now doesn't like this and that
harrison's becoming fond of kurt
caldwell which a lot of people predicted
pretty obvious that was gonna happen
but we're learning now that
harrison seeing him as like a father
figure this episode you kind of see this
tension between dexter and kirk caldwell
there but also dexter learning more
about kirk caldwell and really
getting this reveal that he now knows
that kirk caldwell is a serial killer
and that angela from last episode knows
that
dexter is actually dexter morgan so
everyone's learning information now
that's important to get the ball rolling
and you kind of feel this tension
throughout the episode that really works
i also have little scenes in this
episode that
really reveal a lot about character
that's quick and actually kind of funny
and i enjoyed was kurt trying to fix the
eye that was removed on chloe when he
shot her i thought was just hysterical
how frustrated he gets and it's just
not the way he wants it to be and what
this does is it sets off curtin to like
jonesing state right to successfully
do his fix here and that's why he's so
kind of off his game and a little odd
this episode especially when he goes to
the diner and he tries to snag this girl
but thank god her boyfriend shows up and
he's doing it so fast not as nuanced as
he does the slow game usually like he
did with chloe and he also just jumps
the gun here with molly so what i liked
about this episode where it worked like
old dexter is that dexter has a hunch
and he's following it and he's following
it about
molly thinking molly's the one who
basically figured him out because she's
got this podcast about different serial
killers and talks about the bay harbor
butcher and i like that they show dexter
listening to that podcast and then
bringing up jokes again and his reaction
to it and i think it's very realistic in
the times we're in because really the
biggest start to steal the killers today
the ones that haven't been caught
are these true crime podcasters because
they're relooking the cases that have
kind of been forgotten about or you know
detectives really have given up on but
everything ties together really well all
these different plot lines in this
episode and i did really like in this
episode before we get back to the molly
stuff is that when we're gonna see now
this big moment of angela confronting
you know jim lindsey that he's dexter is
that angela literally
says to him just like deborah at one
point you're the one who needs therapy
and a lot of people have talked about
how similar they are and i i really like
how they're kind of connecting that
subconsciously and she says
relationships are built on trust how can
i ever trust you jim i like that angela
doesn't just turn
over here to dexter and fall fully into
his trap and i love little lines that
dexter says like when he's leaving are
you gonna keep my secret you know lines
like this michael c hall is just the
master at and
you know he's always saying a little bit
of truth but it's obviously not the full
truth and it's fabricated to get
through the next day as dexter morgan
and what he wants but it's still him
struggling of being truthful with people
he cares about and
that blends in well with having the
therapy session here with harrison and
that harrison and him are addressing
abandonment issues but he's still not
being honest even in therapy and this
really makes harrison like he says feel
abandoned
in that just current setting they're in
and
i really like deb and her appearance is
one of her best appearances to me that
really wasn't over the top and served
the purpose of the plot and character
and i like that she's you know saying
things to dexter like you're talking to
your dead sister right now and you were
raised as a serial killer by your
adopted cop dad and your mother was
butchered in front of you you know like
just talking about the character
reminding us in that moment things he
should be actually addressing that he
never does and you see the therapist
brings up inherited trauma which is a
big theme in a lot of shows now
talking about that so i like that
they're kind of delving into that with
harrison here and even the therapist
bring up the magnolia quote was good
where he's like we may be through with
the past but the past isn't through with
us and dexter's just like i didn't see
that one just again great little humor
there were dexter but it's a true theme
about this season with dexter and his
son he has to face these things with
harrison if they're ever going to have a
healthy relationship in his past and it
was interesting to see just dexter
you know face to face with the sun
facing the hurt harrison felt about him
abandoning him and how dexter is going
to react to that if if he will change
but he's got that voice of debra's head
that you know like she says people know
the truth in your life have died so will
he go that way because he's been tempted
to tell harrison all the truth but you
know deborah's like it's too dangerous
and she thinks it's selfish on his part
and again this is part of dexter's brain
it's not actually deborah now i want to
give a shout out to the actor of logan
here i think he's doing a great job and
i think he's so likable and what makes
me even more likeable is him talking
about his spotify breakup playlist and
how this
through logan dexter finds out about
molly and angel working together on
something secret but it's not initially
what he thinks about the bay harbor
butcher it's actually about matt but
logan also we learned he
is someone who's a fan of kirk caldwell
so when angela's bringing up the
suspicious activity by him you know this
might end up being a blind spot for
logan and we'll see how that
forms because it is a little biased that
he's close with this person who's now
going to be a suspect so the show's
constantly giving us a push and pull
about what exactly is the deal with
harrison who is this man really and
harrison sneaks into audrey's room i
like this she has the nunchucks so that
was pretty funny but he opens up to
andre and they're bonding about being
outsiders but he's like i'm just angry
all the time i think about hurting
people and he mentions that ethan wasn't
the first person he's hurt and that he
hurt someone who touched him at a bus
stop so again it's pulling you back to
like okay maybe harrison's a lot like
dexter but i'm guessing from last
episode we thought harrison might be
more normal than we thought he's gonna
be somewhere in the middle and you
notice he's got the trinity blade in his
back pocket as well and he gets it on
with audrey but you know dexter records
kurt and molly's conversation at lunch
and
he's listening back in the car i like
how they did this
and listening to their conversation he
recorded
and he's like but the last thing we need
is where in the world is a mat called
all podcasts which i love because dexter
sees he's off the hook sort of but then
she's still focusing something he really
doesn't want her on and i like that he
kind of even has a moment thinking about
just letting molly get killed in kurt's
cabin because it will get rid of that
problem but what's crazy is dexter in a
sense ended up saving molly's life here
and it was pretty stupid of molly
knowing that he's already a suspect here
kurt caldwell to even go through that
basement like i could see her going
there but just going through the door
when you see it's underground i was like
okay i know she had like the mace or
something there but it was a little
that made me roll my eyes a bit like no
way with this true crying podcaster go
through that door but i love that dexter
actually interferes here and ironically
saves molly's life and
he goes
inside of the room and forces the issue
on kirkus he's panicking now and he gets
to see i'm happy they didn't hold that
out that dexter sees he's a serial
killer sees the cameras and knows right
away but it's interesting because
molly still wants to keep quiet
about all this happening because she's
like angela didn't want me looking into
this so i'm now thinking molly's not
going to actually tell angela yet
what they found out about kurt which
might slow things down and maybe what
angela finds out but we know which we'll
get to the big reveal at the end of
angela finding that body but i have my
theories on that and my theories on that
is because dexter says narration is
never good to kill the son of a serial
killer right but then says very
confidently that kurt is death the
killer angela is looking for but
i think it's too easy that he's also the
killer of these missing girls that
they're really looking at that yes
kurt's mo is these
girls he actually takes but i don't know
if they're the same ones that are
related to angela finding this body of
iris because you even see in the
previously on this episode from a
previous episode that
angela mentions to curt the caves and
that she's gonna look through them and
he doesn't go and move any bodies and if
it was him it makes me think wait a
minute if that is the body of iris that
he's responsible for he would have at
least tried to take that out of there
right because he knows angela was on to
the cave so i think this might be where
this billionaire comes in who bizarrely
we haven't seen in like forever i feel
like it's like he's forgotten about so
it will still kind of feel strange if
he's even brought in because he had so
much screen time in the first like two
episodes and then has been gone but it
must be his purpose he has to have more
purpose to the story right that he might
just be a separate type of killer
because we know he's a racist guy and
that he might be the one who has these
missing girls that's in that case that
is the big case that's been going on for
years in the town or here's a long shot
theory uh which is totally long shot
probably not but it could also be teddy
because teddy's with her he's the one
who says to her he's never seen a body
before she's a little hesitant going to
the cave and when they find the body
he's not seeming like someone who's
seeing a body for the first time so i
wouldn't count him out either that could
be crazy but and again it could just be
kurt right i'm looking too far into this
but there's got to be a reason the
billionaire is in this and again it
wouldn't doesn't make sense to me being
kirk because again why wouldn't he get
rid of that body of iris if he knew
angela was gonna go to the caves
eventually and that moment will end the
episode angela calling dexter like i
don't need jim i need dexter morgan so
that's gonna be interesting conversation
about her finding iris in the body and
what that's gonna lead to with dexter
kurt and everybody and the other
important scene here is with harrison
because he has this wrestling match you
know and kurt to harrison during the
wrestling match is like use that anger
unleash on that [ __ ] and it's so much
like john crease and the karate kid
sweep the leg moment there
sweep the leg
you have a problem with that
[Applause]
no sensei
no mercy and harrison snaps his freaking
arm which was crazy you knew that was
coming and dex actually is being a good
dad here you know snapping a curt and
telling harrison is not right what he
did so i i like that was actually the
best dad thing dexter has done yet with
harrison but this episode like i said as
a whole is back on track for me it feels
like earlier in the season to me where i
was really enjoying the episodes it's
just solid i'm gonna give this one
actually a nine i did really think it
was really good and every scene i
thought was really effective here and
was interesting and a little more
investment and again didn't feel like
all these contrived things happening
that were super cheap code like that
last episode uh
don't even get me started about angel
again saying harrison's name just oh my
god i won't let that down but i'm so
happy you know different writers here
this episode you can see again it just
felt more grounded it felt more
intimate and again like i learned more
about all the characters but also
naturally moving the plot along and not
forcing things artificially so yeah i
really enjoyed this and this got me more
excited for what's to come and next week
you know we'll see what happens i don't
see trailers with these screeners so i
have not seen the trail that's come out
i'm excited to watch that but you know
we'll see what's going to happen with
kurt i do think there's two killers
involved here and separate cases with
there's got to be someone else doing
especially the missing indigenous girls
that angela's been talking about it
can't just be kurt that would just be so
easy so we'll see but yeah we also got
to see more about harrison it's always
again this back and forth and harrison
snapping this guy's arm is huge it's a
huge moment of his anger showing that he
was talking about audrey but still does
it put him towards the area of a dexter
where he might have killed people i
don't think so but we'll see let me know
what you thought of it down below i'd
love to hear your thoughts i read every
comment i try to respond as many as i
can and please make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss one of my reviews of
dexter i'm also reviewing the witcher
right now and you also see my reviews
for the wheel of time i also do movie
reviews and celebrity interviews please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram for more of me and
tiktok as well and if you really like
what i do here appreciate become a
member it helps me so many ways i'll be
able to do more reviews for you guys
it'll be a dream come true for me if you
support me that way and everyone just be
friendly in the comments you know it's
just opinions this is the show you know
so don't make it personal it's not fair
to me or any other commenters everyone
just be civil and be adults
and i'll see you next week